[Applause]
look rasheed
i'm gonna make this really nice and easy
for you i need names and you're gonna
give them to me you have to listen to me
you have to listen to me this is
all a huge mistake
department of homeland security's been
monitoring your calls for weeks
regime we got you we know about you and
your friends
we know that you're a terrorist i am
a terrorist we
me my friends we breed dogs specifically
terriers
we write terrorist fiction we we we
spend
a good deal of time discussing possible
future terrorist plots
it's a nice try really is
but it's bull rashid
come on is that the best you got what
now come on
i'm listening just tell me tell me tell
me about this imminent attack
what what what the title i don't know
what to do what are you talking what am
i talking about i don't know huh
huh i don't know what you're talking
about what i'm telling you no you don't
know
i don't know i don't know june 11th
rajeed
you spoke of an imminent attack oh oh
yes
that was my friend listen his dog bit
him
and i told him if you do not train them
another terrier attack
is imminent
so you lied and you see what happens
come on regine i like you let's be
friends huh
now you still haven't explained to me
why we found on the search engine of
your computer
the words target washington 49 times
that that is because i was in dc for a
dog show and i had to buy a squeezy toy
a birthday card and some deodorant
all at an affordable price all right you
can only do that
again yeah okay i see how you want to
play this
this is not a case ah mistaken identity
rajid
oh and you know it fella we've heard the
conversations
between you and jafar were you
discussing your hatred of american ideas
american idols i hate them they perform
dancing queen
it was a desecration through allah
my favorite band we got you on tape
referring to jafar
as one of the architects of 7-eleven
it was 7 11.
[Music]
he designs convenience stores
7-eleven oh
wilson dogs just attacked the capitol
building
were they terriers how did you know
you